il marche dans les pas de jeananti Touré
la francontoise a 24 ans quand la
Révolution française éclate elle a
grandit dans cette campagne faite de
roche et d'eau à cette époque les
prêtres réfractaires sont pour chassés
et ils s'abritent dans la grotte de la
Baume c'est l'unique chemin qui va au
cte de la Baume là donc portait la
nourriture au prêtres qui se cachaent
pendant les révolution donc qui venaent
de Suisse qui venait là les accompagner
auprès des malades la nuit
surtout plus de 230 ans plus tard ces
habitants du vallon de sensais dans le
doux n'ont pas oublié l'engagement de
cette religieuse hors du commun on voit
sa détermination il faut regarder son
seul portrait officiel vous regardez ce
regard vous dites pour une une jeune
femme c'est vraiment quelqu'un de de
très déterminé et puis elle avait une
volonté farouche pour faire le bien pour
qui que ce soit et sa première chose que
je trouve qui est fondamental et qu'on a
retrouvé à de multiples égards c'est de
s'occuper des filles parce que
finalement quand on investit dans les
filles on investit pour le futur pour
les futurs enfants pour la jeunesse et
pour l'avenir d'un pays s Nicole Marie
fait plus que marcher dans les pas de
jeanti Touré comme elle elle a décidé de
consacrer sa vie à Dieu en aidant les
jeunes les pauvres et les malades
aujourd'hui qui d'autre qu'elle et les
amis de jalantide viennent encore
marcher dans les pas d'une sainte il y a
des ronneurs puisque il y a tout un
itinéraire qui est fait qui conduit à
GRTE de la bombe il y a des pèlerins et
par exemple l'été aussi nous accueillons
de nos sœurs un petit peu de différentes
nationalités du monde entier et pour
elle c'est un moment important de se
retrouver là à la grotte où jeanantide a
marché où elle a vécu quelquefois même
célèbre
l'aristie Jeane Antide est la fondatrice
de l'ordre des sœurs de la charité
aujourd'hui près de 1800 femmes
répondent à son appel et elles sont
présentes dans le monde
entier c'est dans cette église de sensé
qu'en 1782 jeanantide demande à Marie de
la prendre sous sa protection elle
venait de perdre sa mère elle avait 16
ans les chemins de randonnée mènent les
pèlerins ou les touristes jusqu'à la
maison natale de jeananti
au mur la devise de la congrégation Dieu
seul les visiteurs découvrent la vie
d'une jeune femme intrépide réfractaire
aux idées de la Révolution elle part en
Suisse et en Allemagne puis elle revient
dans son village de sensé et là y est
resté plusieurs mois en faisant la
classe en s'occupant des chrétiens en
soignant les malades ici à sensé mais
aussi dans tous les villages à l'entour
bien plus tard en 1928 une basilique est
construite à sensé en 1934 l'Église
catholique la déclare sainte et c'est en
1959 que la basilique accueille une des
reliques de janantide toute cette
histoire est racontée au promeneurs
trois parcours retracent la vide de la
personnalité culturelle historique et
religieuse de sensé
elle a un tel impact sur le le valallon
que c'est une évidence de parler de
sainttejanantide la laïcité c'est pas
oublier son histoire la laïcité c'est la
neutralité de l'État l'état n'oublie pas
son histoire Louis XIV Saint-Louis
Charlemagne c'est l'histoire de France
saintjanantide c'est l'histoire de sensé
celui qui veut marcher sur les traces de
jeananti Touré vient aussi à Besançon à
la demande de prêtre elle ouvre en 1799
une école aux 13 rues des Martelot il
suffit juste de traverser la rue pour
aller chez les sœurs de la charité et
visiter l'exposition dédiée à la
fondatrice de leur
ordre l'école c'était quand même une
nouvelle expérience pour elle quand
quand on pense qu'elle a suivi seulement
6 mois d'école à sensé quand on pense
qu'elle a appris à écrire toute seule à
après 20 ans et qu'on lui demande
de de faire de nouvelles des écoles quoi
pour les les enfants et ces écoles elles
étaient gratuites Jean Antide fonde
aussi un bouillon pour les plus pauvres
sous Napoléon elle s'investit pour
améliorer le sort des prisonniers de
bevau de siècles plus tard l'association
la boutique jeanantide propose toujours
un accueil de jour à ceux qui n'ont pas
de toit l'engagement de jeanantide est
tellement actuel que la sainte est l'un
des personnages qui a donné son nom à
l'une des rames du tram de
Besançon